the big kung pao chicken in the room is  that we have not yet discussed much is  China for years the United States has  leaned on China to pressure North Korea  on its nuclear weapons program to  evidently zero success this week China's  vice Commerce Minister insisted quote we  think the North Korea nuclear issue and  China US trade are in two completely  different domains they aren't related  they should not be discussed together  well there's a new sheriff in town and  president Trump has promised to do just  that finally tie trade to North Korean  nukes critics will shriek about the in  efficacy of this tactic but it couldn't  possibly do worse than our previous  quarter century of failed policy on the  peninsula  I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael  Nolt show come back tomorrow we'll do it  again  [Music]  [Music]